so you have not been attacked by people
from the church I mean even not really I
was told by three separate three
separate people that I was on a Vatican
watch list for a while and I thought
that was a joke until I found out that
it really wasn't a joke that was was
actually a apparently that was a thing
and I was like why am I on a Vatican
watch list and they said well you have a
globally syndicated show you wrote a
book on the
rosary yeah you're on the Vatican watch
list I was like oh I was like and it's
like what priest sniper like how does
that what does that mean like what does
that look like and I guess I was just oh
they're watching yeah I guess they
wanted to know like you know is this
somebody we have to look out for the
reason why I said not yet is that I have
a very very big concern about the
Evangelical Christian Movement that's
happening now within the world and
specifically in the States because
number four on their target list behind
the
lgbtqia you know agenda is this type of
work so really oh yeah there's a list of
and where they come in the you can find
their Christian breakfast where they all
pledge their little things on their
Board of what they're what they're
attacking and anything that would be of
the occult which I think is very
interesting because they chose to use a
word that's literally decades old as
opposed to if you walk into a bookstore
today it's now under self transformation
or New Age and what do you think the the
reaction would be like what do you think
being number four what could that
possibly lead to well you know I think
it was really really scary cuz my
cousin's gay and she is married to a
woman right and was very concerned about
certain things in the last decade of how
things would shift and I I kind of like
I don't want to I don't want to say I
laughed it off but to assuage her
feelings I said I don't I don't think
you have to worry about certain things
because you know there were certain
achievements that we've had societally I
go and I think the anthropological
reaction in society would be backlash I
go I really wouldn't worry and she said
you may be psychic but you don't know
jack about politics or the
government and she goes I do and
everything that she told me that was
going to happen in her prediction has
come to pass and that was in